[Music]
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about
whatever we want we got sherry cola
yo look how cute
do you guys know what that is because i
don't know sherry cola gudetama stickers
basically this is like some hardcore
copyright uh
situation i'm waiting for a cease and
desist email
but no like it's fan art some someone
uh made me into a gudetama was that the
egg candy yeah it's the egg
oh jono the egg [ __ ] none of us knew
what the [ __ ] she was talking not a
candy it's
the lazy egg oh he doesn't know
anyway i love this stuffed animals you
got in the cranes oh
the cranes i have a question i've been
wanting to ask you
so you're one of the first shanghainese
people i know that actually speak
shanghainese can you say something
yeah uh uh
young that sounds mandarin
i said my boob is a little bit itchy
right now that's what you said
nana is booboo says that one more time
i don't know how do you say boobs in
mandarin say something you could say in
mandarin okay uh mandarin okay okay let
me say something and
say the car hit me and i fell off the
bridge english mandarin
okay fine and then fine english oh yeah
nice english and then japanese and
yeah and thai english um um
i want to eat rice
on tuesday okay mandarin
fun
uh japanese i don't know how to say
tuesday
oh gohan that's just i want to eat food
i like it
so you grew up in shanghai so i was
around
thai oh oh oh oh what are you writing
only rice
[Applause]
so tan is the day part so all the days
are like one chan
one put one soup but i can't remember
tuesday
jan is uh lime in vietnamese though i do
know a little bit like
but isn't it the same eat rice and eat
food is the same thing because gohan is
rice and it is food too for us
i should wait wait what is it like sick
fun right that does that means eat rice
but it also means eat food that's the
same time yeah right it's like universal
same here same here food too like when
you use it
in sick fun like it is just eat food eat
you know
but then like fawn by itself is rice
cooked rice
because we also have breakfast lunch and
dinner too we say that too wait raw rice
is a different one
oh uh might is uh uh the the grain you
brought
wait how do you guys do like uh eat
breakfast lunch and dinner because
breakfast lunch and dinner is like
uh morning rice like afternoon rice and
night rice mandarin
mandarin is like morning meal dalton oh
yeah yeah wait what about it's fine i
just say it's all fine sometimes some
fun
one that's true yeah yeah that's the
thing that's the thing but you know how
shanghainese is kind of similar to
mandarin but like not
like um like it's actually really
different no well
maybe i hear it it sounds the same to me
like for example i
have to do homework because she has some
french [ __ ] in there yeah it does sound
funny the ceviche at the end she said
ceviche it sounded crazy
yeah yeah yeah you're right no whenever
i'm on the phone people think
i'm french as [ __ ] with my mom is there
french influence in shanghai no not at
all in vietnamese though i just keep
mentioning
vietnamese people i know that one um
like okay so
i have to do homework and a little bit
of frog
in french cuisine i've had frog legs if
you haven't
asian's been doing that asians are doing
that yeah i like to lick frog legs
oh frogs that's complicated yeah i'm
just doing the easy stuff
um so i have to do homework
see french is fun
in shanghai do they still speak
shanghainese or are they speaking
mandarin now they speak chinese but they
also speak mandarin so mandarin of
course is more universal because like
yeah even kanto people might speak
mandarin um
uh taiwanese people like hong kong deep
okay it comes from guangdong which is
uh an actual city in china but then why
isn't it called guangdong
china canton yeah they just kind of
anglicized it
yeah yeah interesting i i gave sharia
why people [ __ ] it up pretty much
yeah i gave her a little lesson in thai
the other day because randomly we're
texting i forgot what about
and um it was last night by the way the
other
quarantine got me [ __ ] up bro but um
not i was telling her how
uh in thai the number five is huh so
[Music]
when thai people are texting like
laughing they go five five five five
five
because i thought it was cute and i was
telling him that
ha in shanghainese is crab so then i
sent him some crab emojis that's cute
is there anything equivalent in in
y'all's anything equivalent there
j-a-j-a yeah no
i know
wait so where up in shanghai is on
i don't know if there is gotta be like
some dentist out there with the look
yeah something um but but shanghai yeah
it's on the it's almost like
kind of near where florida is um on in
the u.s
in china where is it yeah like kind of
where florida florida is shanghai's on
the street
i thought shanghai was in the north no
that's what i thought too that's what i
thought
hong kong would be the florida of china
like hong kong
would be like you're right you're right
i thought i could i was like
beijing maybe virginia i don't [ __ ]
know is that new york
because because shanghai is always
oh yeah yeah oh no it's a geography
hong kong would be the florida i [ __ ]
up i [ __ ] up i [ __ ] up
like the dc like virginia does it snow
there
how high does china go it goes pretty
high i think
this is snow i'll be honest beijing is
not where i thought it was
beijing formerly known as pet king yeah
pet kingdom that's where it came from
people this is the border
wow of china wow so shanghai is right
there pretty close to south korea what
the heck it's a beijing i haven't looked
at a map in a while
did they rearrange or something did they
rearrange this without
it's okay i couldn't tell you where like
idaho is or like
you know no idaho oh i do i do it's the
l
yeah it's the one with the like i know
what it looks like i'm just not sure
where it is in relation to where i'm at
shanghai is poppin how do you say
shanghai and mandarin do you say
shanghai
oh you don't say shanghai oh that was
that the beijing peeps be doing oh
that's what beijing peeps
every city has their own [ __ ]
dialects yeah they do so what did the
baby
do same here same here they probably see
some crazy things you're doing the lispy
stuff in the
venezuela as you know i mean oh no i
mean same here in the u.s
right that's good this is accent stuff
yeah that's accidental
but technically it is accents though
i've talked about how like because you
know
they can read the same characters but
then just say it differently so in a
weird way it is accents yeah
true no it's not
dialect yeah because japanese reads the
same chinese characters but it's
not accent it's a different language how
do you say
how do you say eat rice uh and what
shania shanghainese
right and then mandarin is this is fine
right and then cantonese
it's fine and then taiwanese is japan oh
that's something
it's like way it's taiwanese folks is
way remixed
in taiwanese i'm like what is happening
okay difference between accent versus
dialect an accent
is simply how one pronounces words a
style of pronunciation
a dialect includes not just
pronunciations but also
one's general vocabulary and grammar
exactly so the whole thing has changed
is changing
so isn't it just a different language oh
yeah what the hell's the language
the written is the same yeah i don't
think it's a is it a dialect
because that's just a different language
well the writtens are the same though
yeah and then like the grammar is still
the same the structure
structurally it's the same but i guess
it's like southern slang
versus like california draw it could be
like dialect no that's
accents okay this is what it says it
says languages and dialects are codes
linguists tend to define a language as
the standardized code used in spoken and
written form whereas dialects are spoken
vernacular codes without a standardized
written system
you know what it's like a dialect is
like it's making patois
yeah because it's english words but it's
like kind of right
but then it's like so it's flipped
completely
you know what i'm saying well isn't
accent like hey
i'm uncle turned what your name yeah
right yeah
so that's not that would be in the right
pigeon pigeon pigeon
english is is a dialect oh that's true
so you're saying the same thing but in a
different way versus words just saying
completely different things
exactly that's why i'm thinking
australian english is a
that's an accent so that's an asset oh
no because they have their own words
yeah but vocabulary but that's slang
well that's just like inside jokes
i guess australian dialect i guess you
know they love the word [ __ ] out there
yeah
they really love you you said a bad word
oh my god
i think bloody's the english when he
said they love [ __ ] i was like this guy
loves that [ __ ] word he always says
it he got me saying it too sometimes
buddy
when i was in australia bro all i heard
was you're such a [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] bro you're such a sick cut no mate
mate you're such a sick cup mate
you're such a sick girl well you can't
see it too i feel like in the movies at
least such a
no i dis-encouraged but then i decided
to say covet i don't know where you know
what else is [ __ ]
you gotta watch that [ __ ] because
today's video is brought to you by cushy
baby
all right so uh they sent me a box i got
to clean my booty hole
it was very nice and i recommend this to
you guys
hold on do you have a butthole i hope
you do
then this ad is for you perfect so it's
for everybody yeah
including your dog maybe yep it's hard
to believe that when we go to the
bathroom in this country most of us wipe
instead of wash
for years bidets have been available but
hideously expensive
costing thousands of dollars the hello
tishi modern bidet attachment is here to
democratize the blessings bestowed by
bidets
and offer clean buttholes to everyone
hello tishi cleans your butt with a
precise stream of fresh water for just
79
which is really cheap compared to when
it first came out and attaches to your
existing toilet
requires no electricity or additional
plumbing and cuts toilet paper use by 80
per
cent so the hello ship day pays for
itself in a few months because with
teletush you don't wipe at
all even the best two ply just can't cut
it when it comes to a hands-free
poop experience ditch paper products and
uncomfortable chafing when you switch to
the soothing
cleansing stream of water from a hello
to sheep a day attachment
and every hello tushy bidet attachment
comes with six
a 60-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty join millions of happy
hello tushy customers right now and have
a clean butt with
every flush go to hellotushy.com off the
record to get 10
off yeah this is a special offer for our
listeners go to hellotushy.com
off the record for ten percent off hello
tushie.com
off the record thank you very much so
according to this article here it says
there's
not really a scientific way to split
languages apart from each other you can
say that japanese and swedish are
clearly different languages but some
languages are very similar swedish
norwegian and danish are all very close
to the point where they are pretty much
mutually intelligible
the dialects like scandinavian mofos the
dialects of chinese on the other hand
are not mutually intelligible but they
haven't earned the title of language
that's that's what's weird to me right
because like
if you think about spanish and
all of south america can kind of
understand each other
but it's all just spanish except for
brazil
oh that's portuguese yeah this is how
crazy it is you go to some parts of
china like or like around san dong or
whatever
their dialect those people speaking
their chinese
and a korean person could actually
communicate more
than a chinese person from san dong
speaking uh
mandarin with someone that actually
speaks mandarin yeah that's how crazy
the dialect stretches we're like you can
have a guy that
like their chinese pretty much sounds
korean and they can they can they can
talk to each other somehow that's how
crazy it is yeah
wait what's your mix again cantonese and
taiwanese okay
that's just for me you know i always
thought i don't know if i talked about
it before but
i thought that sign language was the
same like all over the world me too
but it's not i feel so stupid there's an
american silence
yeah asl so here's here's what someone
gave to me as an example right because
in in english window is this
sign language right right but in japan
sign language is
this or something like that and in
prison it's like this
and it's because the windows open
differently in japan
japanese one again it's it's it's it's
either this or i think it's this
it's not it's not a paper one that you
go i think it's this it's not a fan that
you go
are you just like you don't just shatter
it and make it is it
it's not a perfect one the japanese one
oh that's a great stereotype to have
that's really cool though that they even
have the different
uh languages in sign language because
then it's just like unique
to the country but i thought it was such
a cool hack yeah i don't think it's that
cool because i'm like finally a
universal language
that's what i thought but they're not
even universal still there is no such
thing other than emojis
hmm i guess so but then even with that
it's like droids and iphones you know
what i mean it's like
yeah and then and then someone out here
sends like someone in japan
an eggplant and they're like oh
delicious
dinner no but i mean it is an eggplant
though
i mean yeah japanese eggplant's really
good the way they cook it at the
yeah it's fire it's pretty good yeah
with the little bonito flakes and yeah
americans don't even eat eggplant but
yeah also food also america's making
everything sexual is that true
american that's you all the time it's
just me
because even the water droplets right
that means like the peach
the peach that's booty the kitty cat
little puss
what little [ __ ] what about crabs it's
like i got to go to the doctor
no that's hahahahaha i'm looking at your
beanie it's a condom
that's true everything's sexualized what
this actually is
condom oh babe it looks like a condom it
really does actually i didn't think this
through
i didn't think this through well i had
this other um beanie that looks like a
nuva ring so i i didn't i didn't
i didn't wear that one today did you
ever have an uber ring
no what about you no you know what to
say if you like it then you better put a
nuva ring in it that was the original
lyrics speaking of peach
and japanese you guys ever watched iron
chef
network all right so so do you know
what's the japanese the japanese word
for peach is like
or some [ __ ] like okay so there's an
episode of iron chef
and the the early japanese episodes it's
like um
they would dub everything except for the
main chef guy like the main like boss
guy
so he would say everything in japanese
and he would announce like the special
ingredient [ __ ]
so one day you know of course i don't
understand japanese so it's all dramatic
and like lights and music
and all i also was like you know
whatever this was all japanese it's like
momo she cracked me up
[Laughter]
the way it was said it was like
flight slides wait twice or they have to
say it twice
it's momo yeah it's not yeah i think
that's cute i think we have a lot of
uh hella syllables because
you know and what i found out was weird
to me is that the the
the characters in chinese writing it's
one syllable one character is one
syllable right and i was like word
that's crazy yeah it is
wait you have basically yes okay so
japanese
uses chinese writing sure we call it
kanji
right it's but um it's just
it's just we memorized what the words
meant
and we just used our words for those
characters
so okay you have one character in
japanese and kanji and it's so like my
last name is this right so
oh there we go yeah
it's two syllables each
i don't know how to read that one oh do
you know how to read that one that you
all use the same thing the bottom one
you can read
symbols yeah when japanese people took
kanji or the the writing system it was
it was like tang dynasty chinese or some
old [ __ ] so then the characters changed
and you guys have simplified and all
that stuff now so it's a little
different but that is interesting that's
multiple syllables to one thing above i
was gonna say so you're telling me this
whole time
my whole life i thought i couldn't tell
the difference between chinese and
japanese symbols and this whole time
they've been the same one no no
so
japanese characters are very distinct
like you guys have some curvatures that
we don't have
there's three alphabets that's why so
you might not notice the other two
and the korean has those circles yeah
yeah but if you have like a japanese
manuscript that's like all kanji
and then yeah then it'll you can't tell
the difference between the kids
what dude this whole time because thai
is some
like really cool looking stuff it looks
almost like indian sanskrit yeah it's
sand scripty
yeah yeah i i only know how to write my
name
but it's what is it like squiggles dot
dot well kind of
it's like it's like a squiggle in kind
of and then the
the eye noise is just like a little
curve damn and then it's like another
squiggly line situation and that's just
fascinating it's honestly fascinating
because it's just like
stunning like it's so beautiful all the
language is chanted
just like two dots or just still like a
hell of characters
high letters aren't characters they're
actually letters they work like letters
so it's phonetic so yeah so this
is the t this is the eye and then this
is the end oh that's sick
so that's how arabic is too yeah they
have letters so it
aligns with english like that
interesting yeah because even like the
thai alphabet like the way they teach it
is like
like ta ta like everything has a
it's like consonant noise and it's vowel
noise you know what i'm saying so
they're they're letters
do you guys have your abc take
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] racists
[Music]
you